Make a quick break, shall we?
Makuta, it is time we finish this.
Once and for all, I cannot do that, Dr. Seinyor, I either win or retreat.
And if you don't destroy me this time, which I doubt you will escape, and cause havoc beyond your wildest dreams.
In the Universal War, I will prepare it in hiding for one year.
You don't want to?
Well, Makuta, let's end this.
I got him! Come on! Get up! Get over here!
Let me finish him off now. Hold him still.
No!
Snakey, get in there. Suck his soul out.
At least they're not harmless. At least they're not harmful now.
It's a good thing.
Me too.
Fool!
No, it cannot be.
I get them before they try to awaken the bad.
This is it!
This is it, Makuta.
Well, the spirit of destruction meets the weakest person in the world.
Dr. Seinyor, you are the most dimwitted I have met in the cosmos in my travels.
You're going to be traveling to the great beyond when I'm done finished with you.
Fighter mode.
Fight...
Super walking mode.
I get him.
Music, please.
Seinyor, it's...
You dare face the spirit of destruction?
No.
Don't move.
Transform.
E-na-na-na-na-na-na.
E-na-na-na-na-na-na-na.
Pay for what you've done to me.
Dr. Seinyor.
Don't be.
The Universal War.
You...
Have failed.
I have failed.
You have failed.
You freaking stooge.
The super family has defeated me.
You freaking idiot.
See you at the AC.
The tenth movie.
Prepare for the war.
See ya.
At the AC.